it's time for another challenge charlie
so last week I gave you my opinion on
society's current obsession with Fame
this week however I'm going to be making
balloon animals I have no experience in
making balloon animals so this is gonna
be a bit of a challenge for me
I bought a balloon pump and I bought
some modeling balloons as you can see
only the very best first thing I'm gonna
try and make apparently the easiest
thing to start with is a dog look at
this guy blows up his balloons that is
impressive
I'm gonna stick to the pump there's
never any good at tying balloons three
that are roughly the same length and
then we do that two more and then you
turn those into lengths okay legs are a
bit odd but that's fine and then there
we go a little dog I gave him a little
tail like a poodle next up I'm gonna do
a rabbit a small one for the head and
then two long ones for the ears a small
one for the neck and then he said to do
two flower petals I think I saw him do
that but those don't really look like
arms to me let's just say it's a girl
rabbit now twist like that's okay I
don't think I'm doing this right it's
definitely changed from a girl to a boy
now huh okay and there we go it's it's
longing is like a rabbit and arms or
something else and those are its legs
there we go
I ran it now we're gonna make a black
cat I thought it was black apparently
it's green okay so we start with two
little ones which make the cats and
nuzzles and then it's two more little
ones and then five more I don't have
enough hands for this okay and there we
go there's our cats that looks like a
cat well it's more like a bear but it
looks a bit like a can it's like it's
got a little nose and everything ah and
there we go it's a cat kind of is a cat
isn't it I'm pretty pleased with that
next I'm gonna try and make a heart and
because I love you
yeah it looks more like a kidney bean
than a heart there we go that's better
next up I'm gonna make a sword in pretty
pink
apparently swords are really easy you
just fold them like that and then twist
it in the middle and then that's it ah
mixed up I'm gonna do a piggy to make
the snout do you have to push this in
like this that and then twist and then
you get to the piggy snout then I have
to make a head like the one I made with
the cat and they have it there's your
little pink flower I've given to me is
but his head is kind of malformed I've
given him little pig trotters this is
odd that is not the tail of a pig that
is the tail of a squirrel just so it's
completely clear next I'm gonna do a
motorcycle which uses two balloons and
there we go it's a tree tell you what
I'm gonna make one more I'm gonna make a
yellow Mouse yeah that's the snout and
those are the ears that give it a head
and now it has lengths but its head is
facing the wrong way and there are the
back legs I kind of want the whole town
to look like that I don't know does that
look better now that there's a letter
tool so there we go
today I have made a dog I've made a
rabbit I've made a cat I've made a pig I
made a sword her I made a tree I made a
mouse and I made a heart and now I'm
gonna do what any loving parent would do
to their kids I'm going to destroy them
with a pair of scissors
goodbye pig now it looks like the dog
has already turned into a dragonfly
goodbye dragonfly swordfights goodbye
little mouse come on
goodbye everyone you've just had the
almost imponderable joy of watching
Charlie is so cool like which makes you
like cool